here are the steps that are required to
be rich you got to finish High School
you don't have babies before you get
married you have to get a job if you do
those three things you will not be
permanently poor in the United States by
all available metrics and evidence
that's the first step then to actually
get rich you have to develop a skill set
that people want from you wealth lies at
the Nexus of three things things that
you're good at things that people want
from you and things that you're
passionate about in that sweet spot is
where the money is for you and that can
be in virtually anything it really can
be because this is a giant country and
it's a huge International economy and
there markets in pretty much everything
I know people who are loaded as plumbers
I know people who have made an enormous
amount of money by starting like cell
phone kiosks at the mall yeah I know one
person in particular good friend of mine
he literally sold the company for
hundreds of millions of dollars he
started off by selling like cell phones
at a kiosk in the all you can do these
things but you have to find that in
Access